jetzt möchte ich aber über ein thema
sprechen was mich sehr bewegt und zwar
die flutopfer in deutschland ich muss
wirklich sagen es war die nachrichten
krise in deutschland bewegt hat wir
haben immer noch die schrecklichen
bilder vor augen und wir haben auch in
der gesellschaft damals zusammen
gehalten etliche freiwillige die dort
sind auch immer noch gibt ihm damals
dorthin kann man noch immer noch dort
sind und die haben unser dank verdient
denn ohne sie habe ich mir heute sagen
lassen von thomas sulzer den
redaktionsleiter bild südwest wäre die
lage dort gar nicht so gut wie sie ist
ich habe heute überlegt ich möchte
darüber sprechen weil ich das gefühl
habe dass die flutopfer in der
gesellschaft vergessen werden und auch
von der politik ich erwarte da ist ja
vielleicht olaf scholz wird auch bald
mal vorbei fährt vor allem erwarte ich
aber dass wir uns damit beschäftigen in
der gesellschaft nicht einfach sagen
worüber reden wir denn hier noch
deswegen möchte ich kurz den bericht von
unserem reporter von bild vorlesen von
vor ort und zwar geht es darum vom
schraubenzieher bis zur kleinen zeitung
gewissen in containern alles was man
haben möchte man kann sich auch helfer
besorgen anrufen ein mailen doch was
noch fehlt sind heizungen 20 prozent der
leute sind immer noch ohne heizung
dessen teilweise kleine geisterstädte
diese überfluteten häuser da kam ein
teilweise noch gar nicht herein das
versprechen versprechen vom flug
beauftragten war es bis zum winterbeginn
die kaputten straßen repariert sind
jetzt muss man sehen ob sie es bis zum
20 dezember schafft die verwaltung ist
mit zu wenig manpower ausgestattet und
die verwaltung geht darunter mit den
anträgen wenn ich das lese muss ich
sagen das ist nicht ehrlich gesagt auf
gut deutsch ab fakt es wäre als
gesellschaft so eine kleine
aufmerksamkeitsspanne haben ja sonst
jetzt die flutopfer schon auch
eigentlich gar nicht mehr interessieren
und ich finde die politik muss jetzt
reagieren und aber und genau das muss
sie und das schlimme ist dass wir uns
leider wieder viel zu sehr sowohl in
rheinland- pfalz und das schöne ist
jetzt ich kann es nicht in einer partei
fest machen ich habe eine ampel
regierung in rheinland pfalz wo es
schwierig funktioniert ich habe eine
eine sage ich jetzt auch eine
schwarz-gelbe also mit fdp-beteiligung
noch ein westfalen wo es auch nicht
richtig funktioniert aber womit
beschäftigt sich politik in diesen
ländern wieder mit der lieblingsfrage
der deutschen wer war schuld wir müssten
eigentlich genau das anderem an wir
müssen sagen die warum funktioniert
privates so viel schneller so viel
besser private und staatliche nicht und
da komme ich zu dem ergebnis klar wird
keinen wundern liberaler der sagt na ja
klar wenn du immer glaubt der staat wird
schon alles regeln dann merkt er kann es
nicht und wenn du meinst die bürokratie
wird es regeln dann hast du den 27
durchschlagen nicht ausgefüllt und
währenddessen verrottet dein haus hinten
wir müssen uns klar darüber werden dass
der staat eben nicht alles kann aber
dass man dann gefälligst auch die die
helfen können sie auch lässt und dann
sage ich aber auch zum schutze von
manchen beamten der angst hat zu
entscheiden weil er meint er hat nicht
die dritte durchführungsverordnung
richtig gelesen die vom bund über das
landeskommando gekommen sind er darf es
machen und nachher sagt man war nicht
ganz richtig aber sie sind froh dass du
wieder zwei leuten der heizung gegeben
hast das
haben politiker von der fdp wann waren
sie zuletzt vorrat ich war zuletzt vor
ort vor jetzt woran ich glaube
dreieinhalb wochen ist nicht mein
wahlkreis könnte ich jetzt sagen aber
auch weil ich eines nicht machen weil
ich wenig diesen gründen tourismus waren
politiker kurt sich mal an wie schlecht
es geht sondern was ich mache ist und
das tun wir über die hilfen die wir ja
auch im bund an bestimmten stellen jetzt
verlängern müssen weil der bund obwohl
theoretisch nicht zuständig und
juristisch nicht zuständig ja auch hilft
was sind die richtigen maßnahmen was
müssen wir machen und auch noch das
kommt als nächstes drauf was ist denn
wenn beim nächsten mal wieder so ein
hochwasser kommt dass wir nicht dasselbe
noch schlimmer haben die können wieder
helfen aber und das sage ich deutlich
ich merke dann auch manchmal wo du
eigentlich denkt ich würde jetzt lieber
dahin fahren und uns sozusagen selber
was machen weil du merkst dass du da
nicht richtig durchkommst herr platz
wird für die flutopfer in deutschland
genug getan von seiten der politik oder
sind sie schon vergessen also ich fand
damals schon richtig dass sehr schnell
hilfen beschlossen wurden auch relativ
unbürokratisch und dass man sich bemüht
die schnell auszuzahlen aber in der tat
ist das nicht nur bei dieser krise zu
beobachten sondern auch bei anderen
krisen das ist häufig so zwei drei
wochen aufmerksamkeit gibt dann guckt
das ganze land drauf dann ist aber immer
noch ganz viele ungelöst und dann gucken
viele schon woanders hin und deswegen
finde ich es auch sehr gut dass sie
heute in der sendung noch mal dran
erinnern und man auch gut dass wir
tatsächlich bei dieser sache
parteiübergreifend handeln dass da
brauchen wir nicht irgendwie regierung
und opposition und wieso ein
parteipolitisches kapital sondern müssen
da wirklich an einem strang erbeten flut
büro eingerichtet haben heute nur die
arbeit der kollegen vorgetragene
deutlich machen was ganz tolles sich da
so engagieren focus hat übrigens auch
ein flug pro focus online eingerichtet
nicht dass jetzt immer nur für uns
selbst loben es gibt schon mehrere
medien die darauf noch weiter achten ich
habe meinen sohn jonathan im frankfurter
büro und der war dort vor ort
tatsächlich auch in der mir berichtet
die lage ist weiterhin katastrophal also
20 prozent ist glaube ich eine gute
schätzung von den menschen den man auch
keine heizungen haben die menschen sind
wirklich immer noch verzweifelt manche
fangen an ihre häuser aufzubauen
natürlich auch mit staatlicher hilfe
muss man sagen gut dass die kommt und
schnell kommt aber auch genauso gibt es
immer noch verzweifelt sind und nicht
wissen was ist und natürlich erlebt
haben wie dieser tsunami der
aufmerksamkeit über sie hereinbrach es
war ja auch noch wahlkampf mit allen
folgen das hatte erinnern uns an die
lacher von armin laschet aber natürlich
auch mit der geballten aufmerksamkeit
die bundeskanzlerin war zweimal da die
fernsehteams waren die reporter und
jetzt ist das auf einmal alles weg und
sie leiden sicherlich nicht an
aufmerksamkeit im zug aber sie hätten
schon gern jemanden regelmäßig der kommt
sich das
könnte helfen auch konkret denn das
wurde mir dass ich auf meinem sohn
erzählt es gibt ganz viele praktische
probleme immer noch vor ort und die
verstehe nicht warum können wir hier
nicht irgendwo hilfe haben und eine
stelle haben gesagt okay bei uns
funktioniert dies und das nicht und und
es wird schnell geholfen ja also ich
meine nicht bewundert die menschen die
dort mit ihren eigenen händen wieder
aufbauen die dann schauen was können sie
eigentlich selbst tun die privaten
initiativen sie haben das angesprochene
fricke sie sind das läuft ja immer
wieder mal schneller ein und der stadt
wir haben das ja auch in berichten
gehört von betroffenen der stadt krebs
zum teil er dazwischen und verhindert
dass unbürokratisch geholfen werden kann
und wenn ja wenn man ihre genehmigung
sind genau wenn dann diese menschen das
vertrauen in den staat weiter haben
beziehungsweise in institutionen und
nicht verloren haben über die
vergangenen monate dann nötigen wir das
muss ich sagen aller allergrößten
respekt ab denn ich glaube wenn ich in
so einer situation wäre und sehen würde
auch wie langsam mühlen mahlen wie sehr
sich viele in privaten initiativen
bemühen und dann aber auch immer wieder
blockiert werden oder hilfe gar nicht
oder hilferuf gar nicht die ankommt und
dann zu sagen trotzdem noch ich glaube
an dieses demokratische system und
glaube dass auch institutionen helfen
können dann finde ich das bewundernswert
essens und muss sagen respekt hut ab